[Música]
desde cuba colombia anunció que aspira a
reanudar las conversaciones con la
guerrilla de la ln por otro lado este
país también nombró al ex senador
armando benedetti como nuevo embajador
en venezuela que a su vez designó al ex
canciller félix placencia para ser su
representante en bogotá
la fiscalía abre una sexta investigación
contra el presidente peruano pedro
castillo cinco de ellas se encuentran
activas castillo es hasta ahora el único
mandatario en funciones en la historia
de perú que ha sido investigado por el
ministerio público
en argentina la inflación se aceleró en
julio hasta el 74 % respecto de junio y
alcanzó el nivel más alto desde 2002
entretanto en los últimos 12 meses
acumuló un incremento del 71 por ciento
el más alto en tres décadas según
informó el instituto nacional de
estadísticas y censos tenemos informe
desde buenos aires
hola y bienvenidos a las noticias de
américa por france 24 los saluda andrés
meza muñoz
empezamos en colombia que anunció que
espera reanudar las conversaciones con
la guerrilla del eln en cuba así lo dio
a conocer el canciller álvaro leyva
desde la habana donde viajó en compañía
de una delegación del gobierno el
diálogo con él ln se había suspendido en
2019 bajo el gobierno de iván duque y
recientemente este grupo mostró su
disposición de conversar con el
ejecutivo de gustavo petro luís muñoz
con los detalles para dos en dos cuba
volvería a ser sede para la paz así lo
anunció álvaro leyva durán el canciller
colombiano tras una visita a la habana
en una delegación de alto nivel
aspiramos a reanudar los diálogos con el
ejército de liberación nacional en el en
esta tierra de paz a fin de iniciar el
camino propuesto por el presidente petro
urrego de alcanzar la paz total
también habló su homólogo cubano bruno
rodríguez ambos responsables de la
diplomacia coincidieron en eliminar a
cuba como país patrocinador de
terrorismo
clasificado así por eeuu por no
extraditar a diez cabecillas de ln tras
el fracaso de las anteriores
negociaciones de paz son incalculables
los puntos y las consecuencias
humanitarias que ha tenido para cuba y
el pueblo cubano dicha inclusión
infundada e injusta colombia firmó un
acuerdo de paz con las farc en 2016 era
la guerrilla más grande y antigua de
américa latina el gobierno de juan
manuel santos también mantuvo
conversaciones con él en estas se
estancaron en 2018 con el gobierno de
iván duque son más lentas como explicó
el experto víctor de currea lugo para
france24 uno de los grandes mitos que se
maneja que deben estar
ln de una concepción asamblearia de es
purgar y estación y esto le plantea
estar haciendo consultas por eso
mientras la carne volteaban de una
manera directa por comandantes estaban
allí la delegación de diálogo del pacto
l lln tienen que venir a colombia para
hacer culta fundado bajo ideología
marxista-leninista lln cuenta con
alrededor de 2.300 efectivos tiene
presencia tanto en colombia como en
venezuela donde es uno de los grupos
armados más poderosos
y es que el ejecutivo de gustavo petro
también dio pasos con miras a
restablecer las relaciones diplomáticas
entre colombia y venezuela petro nombró
como embajador en caracas al ex senador
armando benedetti y la noticia se dio
solo minutos después de que el
presidente nicolás maduro también
anunciara que designó al ex canciller
félix plascencia para ser su
representante diplomático en bogotá sin
embargo no se sabe cuándo asumirán sus
cargos ya que ambos países no han
empezado a normalizar sus relaciones
diplomáticas rotas desde 2019
he decidido en respuesta al gobierno
venezolano que ha designado embajador
que tendrá como responsabilidad
normalizar las relaciones diplomáticas
entre los dos países
de signar armando benedetti como
embajador de colombia ante venezuela
esperando el beneplácito de ese gobierno
y también con la ardua tarea de
normalizar las relaciones
entre los dos países quiero anunciar
el ex canciller felipe procedencia
quien fue embajador en la república
popular china
quién
es hoy presidente del centro
internacional de inversiones de
venezuela
he designado como próximo embajador en
la república de colombia y ya la
cancillería de venezuela ha pedido el
beneplácito a la cancillería de colombia
y pronto estará en bogotá vamos a perú
donde hay un nuevo capítulo en la crisis
política que vive el país la fiscalía
general abrió una nueva investigación
contra el presidente pedro castillo por
presunto delito contra la tranquilidad
pública esto mediante la organización de
una estructura criminal conformada por
su cuñada y por funcionarios del
gobierno según la fiscalía este
entramado buscaba favorecer la
licitación de contratos de
infraestructura pública a empresas
cercanas al mandatario
samuel salgado tienen los detalles
nuevo tropiezo para el presidente pedro
castillo la fiscalía general de perú
inició otra investigación en su contra
por presunto delito contra la
tranquilidad pública en la modalidad de
organización criminal esta nueva
investigación también involucra a su ex
ministro de vivienda general alvarado y
a su cuñada jennifer paredes quienes
habrían organizado una estructura
criminal para favorecer a empresas
fachadas amigas del presidente en la
licitación de millonarios contratos para
obras de infraestructura
jennifer paredes se entregó a la
justicia mientras que el castillo afirma
que se trata de una persecución política
por parte del congreso la fiscalía y la
prensa
queridos compatriotas
tienen a través de esa agenda mediática
en the session mediático concluidos
con sectores que nunca han hecho nada
por el perú quieren doblegarnos
este es el sexto proceso que se abre en
contra de castillo desde que asumió su
agitado mandato hace un año el delito
contra la tranquilidad pública podría
implicar una detención preventiva de
mínimo tres años sin embargo los
abogados del mandatario argumentan que
la inmunidad presidencial se impide que
pedro castillo vaya a la cárcel hasta
2026 cuando acabe el periodo por el que
fue elegido en las urnas a la crisis
política que vive el país se suma la
tensión entre el legislativo y el
ejecutivo ahora está echando la culpa a
poder judicial a la fiscalía
a la prensa al al poder legislativo o
sea todos son culpables de lo de los
supuestos delitos que comete en el
congreso de perú avanza un proceso de
acusación a pedro castillo por traición
a la patria debido a pasadas
declaraciones sobre ceder territorio
peruano a bolivia para tener acceso al
mar de ser hallado responsable tendría
que abandonar la casa
en argentina la inflación se aceleró en
julio hasta el 74 % respecto de junio y
alcanzó el nivel más alto desde 2002
mientras el dato anual se ubicó en 71
por ciento el más alto en tres décadas
desde buenos aires- nuestro corresponsal
natalio costo y nos daba previamente los
detalles
este jueves se conoció en argentina la
medición oficial de la inflación para el
mes de julio fue del 74 por ciento sólo
en el mes de julio es la más alta
inflación mensual de los últimos 20 años
en abril de 2002 había estado por encima
del 10% y eso era en el contexto de la
fortísima crisis del año 2001 2002 que
atravesaba el país en julio uno de los
aumentos importantes no el más
importante de los sectores pero muy
importantes fue el 6% en alimentos que
impacta especialmente a las familias más
necesitadas y en los últimos 12 meses la
inflación de todos los productos que
mide la canasta que utiliza el indec que
es el organismo que hace esta medición
en argentina dio un aumento del 71% como
decía en los 12 meses desde julio del
2021 hasta julio del
2022 el ministro de economía en sergio
massa ya había dicho que julio de agosto
en sus expectativas iban a hacer los
meses de mayor inflación y luego espera
que empiece a bajar entre otras cosas
por medidas como la anunciada este mismo
jueves por el banco central que fue de
las tasas de interés de referencia que
va a llevar en las tasas de interés de
los plazos fijos para los ahorristas en
torno al 70% anual de expectativa es que
éstos saquen dinero de la economía que
lo lleve al ahorro y que entonces en
meta menos presión sobre la demanda de
productos y sobre el consumo con una
expectativa de junto con otras medidas
tratar de ir frenando la inflación en
argentina y cerramos en eeuu el fiscal
general merrick garland reveló que fue
él mismo el que autorizó el allanamiento
en la mansión del ex presidente de
donald trump en florida esto en medio de
la investigación contra el ex mandatario
por supuestamente haber sustraído
documentos clasificados de la casa
blanca- garland también pidió a un
tribunal que hiciera público el
documento con los detalles del registro
agregó que estas decisiones no se toman
a la ligera y condenó los ataques que se
han producido contra el fbi
hasta aquí este informativo en france 24
gracias por acompañarnos continúen con
toda nuestra programación
[Música]